déjà je voulais m'exprimer avant la
première question parce que je sais
qu'il y a eu pas mal de questions sur
Pourquoi je parlais pas déjà tous les
journalistes ils sont là c'était rien de
personnel j'avais rien contre les
journalistes rien contre les gens c'est
juste que je sais que j'avais besoin de
et j'ai toujours ce besoin de me
concentrer sur ma compétition et je sais
que quand je vais me concentrer sur
quelque chose j'ai besoin de le faire à
100% et de pas perdre d'énergie dans
d'autres choses mais c'est pour ça que
je souhaitais pas me présenter et j'ai
appris il y a peu que la Fédération elle
allait avoir une amende donc je m'engage
à la payer personnellement il faut pas
que la fédération est paye une décision
qui est personnelle
[Musique]
il est 12h35
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une question à te poser d'accord
alors est-ce que tu préfères avoir
maintenant plein de jouets de la reine
des neiges
ou alors est-ce que tu préfères avoir à
18 ans une voiture rien que pour toi
la Reine des Neiges tu préfères avoir
maintenant plein de jeux de la Reine des
Neiges
mais tu m'as